I finally get it and to read what a  Super Bowl wow what a fun is this board  good Bakri down hats  it really means a lot to keep my own  farewell my dad is starting extreme good  iron Heights hello well Eli men put onto  another thing I'm Oliver Luck lol  because everyone's been moving recently  the charge already would I like to Hulu  I'll do it I'll move I don't think about  you as much as you think I do  I didn't know I was we now own the town  where'd iron Heights is extreme now ok  I'm whatever you want everyone calm down  this will blow over where should I go  here here yeah but you have enough money  though Jason we need drew I save myself  where is the time to give up all you  need right here sir looks like I need  another class exact tailor strip eat  help  Waldo next season Burdine heights will  come back no more come back no one is  ever coming back again  [Music]  Wow  [Music]